I said I was going to start off simple
and you're like really
that's the subheading that doesn't look
simple and I'll let me it doesn't look
simple but it's a simple idea all this
means congruence transformations is what
ways can you change a shape that's
that's a transformation what ways can
you change a shape
so the shape actually remains the same
that's what Congress means okay let me
say that again Congress transformations
are ways that you can change shape so
that after you changed it it's still
kind of the same shape okay
I'll show you what I mean there are
three that's what we might do actually
is a home by the way code words
translations is a bit of a mouthful so
sometimes they just get called
transformations okay to capture what
these all are I'm gonna ask us to draw a
table we're thinking of ways that you
can change a shape so it's actually
still the same shape in the end okay so
I'll start off with the first one and
then I wonder if you can help me get the
other two out and really all the other
things are combinations of these three
okay for each one we're going to name
the transformation and each one has a a
special sort of technical name okay and
then we'll think of what's a more common
word that's a synonym for that so you
can actually think okay rather than
getting confused by all the terminology
okay then I'm going to show you for each
of these transformations in order to do
them you need to have some ingredients
I'll show you what I mean in a second
okay
lastly and this is what the pencil is
mainly for we're gonna draw one I'll
show you what I mean so that you can not
just describe that you can see it okay
so here's my first one okay let's go
black John my first point of
transformation is called translation
you're like that sounds like a language
would it is a language word but we're
thinking about it in the terms of our
shapes and moving around okay I've been
the easiest synonym for translation it
is kind of like sliding so example here
we go here's a rectangle okay eyes up
he's my rectangle now if I slide over
here like so
I've changed it haven't I it like it's
not in the same place anymore but it's
still the same shape it's the same
dimensions you can describe in the same
way I've translated my rectangle okay so
that's why sliding is a similar kind of
word like you're changing its position
in order to know it for example with
this rectangle right now if you and I
wanted to make the same translation okay
you'd need to know where I moved it and
how far right for example maybe I would
say you know move it to the right ten
centimeters well move it down something
like that
so what two things have I given you I've
given you go these ingredients right
which way do I go what's up what's a
word for that direction
ah a direction but you need more than
just a direction right you need to go
how far in that direction what's that
like I said ten centimeters or 50
centimeters a distance excellent okay so
you need a direction and a distance and
then you can do the translation and then
you and I can do the same one right in
fact if you wanted to you could make it
directions and distances right because
you could move or
to the right and down and that would be
a translation right so I could combine a
few together
okay so let's quickly draw one now
instead of doing a rectangular because
that turns out to be rather boring okay
let's do a let off okay let's do a
little gonna be careful I'm gonna pick
the letter R no serious question serious
question I'm gonna ask you later on what
do you think I picked our and not a or B
or T or two I'll let you ever think
about it I don't think about it cuz some
of you already know it and others you
like whatever it's just random maybe
because you like cuz cuz that's Rishabh
starts with uh writing right I'll let
you have a think about it so if we
translated this this is what it would
look like for instance if that was the
direction in the distance that I move to
do alright the shape started I became my
own shape and then it ends up over here
Hacha
so you can see it's still the same shape
it's still congruent that's the a fancy
word for it's the same size you know you
can describe it in the same way but it's
not the same exactly I've changed it
happen thank you alright so there you go
there's a transformation